ciao Michelle sto bene grazie sto
benissimo Bongiorno tutti aah sussulta sei
stato pomodoro non tessuto Tata D impara con
goop angular accarezza cozec aggiuntivi
due tavoli bibite e calpestata
casuale in pericolo pigro canola
impossibile trottarmi hai dimenticato no Joey GK  Lou
dice a una squadra onesta che ci accusa per l'
isola glassa fa la mia decisione Intendo
Foligno a favore di permeabile
So con fervore che Jeff il tofu giusto preferisce
prima che kaihatsu foo otterrà il
servizio di preghiera per il vero inglese e una S così
vivace devo versare don'  t feel more -
importante Harper Tim Permenter Windy
City soldi salute salute condizione
Inglese l'anno scorso in genere sono
intimiditi oh okay vedi pensaba que
cuando NOS Dermot Eva apprendista sushi salon
quando ti benedice Chesson
curve Oh bellissima
Kozak un programma grasso Krista city monitor
kid  tossicodipendente vuole che ci occupiamo del
viaggio di dottorato in inglese altri tre Jordan pero
ovviamente essere il leader del partito Sonja
fondamentalmente
quindi sequenza di razzi sei
diventato personalmente un  altro robot molto bene
nonna ok Quinn il passato semplice
frase Assisi presente semplici futuri
ok mio cugino ora seguirà G porta
GPIO cerca saggezza una postato per cadere
ok bene se hai fatto bene un molto accogliente a
La Crosse importante un qualificatore le
esperienze si accamperebbero oh ok  fallo anche
CEO allo stesso modo il prossimo diventerà
personale a venir a contest II normalmente
quando geli i programmi di utilità sono tutti Jordi
è un pomodoro SIA in una lebretia my uh
Cassata Cristo ok Camacho a lingua
Terra Alden il volume previs torrent
deve essere stato in sumo  acustico credo
dr.  Alfred English vedrai che sarà una
conferma Mathilde ci dia un sacco di
soldi per questa sponsorizzazione
da dire entra così loro ok ciao ciao
ciao ciao andiamo da questo sono dieci virgola
75 cosa sei pazzo
ehi disturbati via oh bello ok grazie
vuoi una borsa o una plastica per favore
amico allora non ne vuoi una lo
porterai a mano
grazie Trafigura
Loschiavo di Baba leggermente soffiato su dai
George ehi ascolta quindi ci siamo
lasciati freccia che differenza fa questo ventosa sarcone
zio Cibo  Mattos betta pre-medieval
scusa el cheapo video Leggenda Khmer Betsy
tirugata Moon Chuck era un gay Borna
grazie signore nel momento in cui vedo George
Harold Arlen davvero pochissimi Laura Mvula
Bambi economia a me mi ha detto alla sua
musica dzasta telefono lì gamba rame
potenziare  l'enigma ma sono le
cose divertenti su madri e padri la
gentilezza interagisce cose divertenti è
tutto a parte quindi Gigi Levangie LA Sagra
studiamo i pidocchi anche un giorno il proprio figlio
è la piccola felicità più disgustosa  se
hai chiamato immagina che pensino ancora
che lui o lei sia
meraviglioso non è un camion come Goyo dovrebbe
collegare grafica empirica mostrarti
i libri del lettore Gwadar ok è una
cosa divertente su madri e padri
anche quando il bambino nella stanza è il più
disgustoso  piccola vescica che potresti mai
immaginare pensano ancora lui chi lei è
meravigliosa rispetto fuori da loro al
college e aprire una ferita in pace t
coccoloso - de que yo no butoh cuesta de
luna compose lei essere isterica cosas
tale feto un Ristorante sì  Quinn do
Machado assegna un determinato dominio yuning
Glaser bandleader
bravissimo no Wawrinka Stralman no
non mi metterà ma non può diventare senior
2% impossibile sorriso sei felice figlio
solo un secondo
io sono cibo Jackson boots nel
frattempo sì
Stillwater, per favore, puoi andare via,
signore, posso avere una zuppa di pomodoro zuppa di pomodoro
sì sì e una pizza italiana al formaggio e
pomodoro quindi ordini la pizza in un
ristorante inglese sì va bene
comunque si apre  fino a diventare manifesti vieni
qui dentro iniziando con un momento inquisitore
per chiamare szustak addenda così qivana
masticato molti dalla situazione
meuk esto pasa amico ft Lord in un dramma
DJ la pobla esercito africano en tant ordina
tonno pizza italiana Grazie senatore
giovane quotidiano razzismo me no
alla stessa casa Queen d7 bidet
vorresti qualcos'altro no non trovo
bevande acqua ferma
ok dov'è il mio ancora qualsiasi come coca cola
vino birra 1 pizzico di birra pinta pinta e
basta grazie a dire veramente
molto molto kabocha a VT visto que yo
mustika molto Paco pero me hotshot
compare a come same ambientale cosa
fácil re-pause llamo diello una otra
cosa que seguramente vo dar una mano
finja Mo Kio Xian turista ok [ __ ]
viaggio con il tostapane me roba
friggin poi me libero alzati poi demo
karel appel
mi scusi signore mi dispiace ma mi sono perso
potresti per favore guarda aiutami a capire
dove sono sì puoi
ok dimmi tutto sto cercando di
arrivare al taglio presumi ok y  Es Mi
piacerebbe avere dei
veri piatti romani Roba di Jenai come la carbonara ok toccare
paga P vite o vino rosso australiano
sai dove potrebbe andare qualche bel
ristorante qualcosa di non molto turistico
sai no sì puoi venire a
casa mia per te se  non vuoi pero SI amo
v eres a Sukkah significava eobeochigi
dire che un dominio di indagine o sussurrare che la
dimensione fisica fosse un formaggio kappa
mr.  stile Derrida pollo ultra
supporto Sony eravamo in diverse aree
il momento a parte ordinario più economico
comprar libro
capacità colloquiale anche se va bene Oh metti una
festa la gente manca Litella quella manifestazione per
essere o non essere nessuno vuole che tu sappia
oggi Bravo Team tell visto yo non
scoraggiato vestroia
è un brindisi clicco all'interno del
mattino democratico buongiorno signore
grazie per esserti assicurato che sono una cameriera
sei una cameriera sì ok abbiamo bisogno come
un mediatore il mio punto
come ti descriveresti è
più difficile ora perché ho male
[  Risate]
nachos di laggiù possibile ragazzo sì una
cosa ci ha dato il nostro colesterolo e Krista
Revis TT Oh mm meno No, quindi metti la tua tazza misura
e non il tuo-- va bene energia multipla
sono solo la narice subconscio
sull'esperimento va bene quindi vai allo sport
IO, va bene, vai dritto sì,
bene, quindi ho bisogno che prenda il
terzo occhio a sinistra, va bene una
conclusione, quindi cerca su Tata torna indietro e vai
in cui è completamente dritto su Suunto
le donne sono su uno schema T maiuscola T
maiuscola niente Pegasus IV così
distribuendo così Tonica principale TK no
seguramente
pentola arcobaleno padre pasta era il tuo corpo
con Episodio II 22 stai strappando erba
disponibile min Vita no Santa per avere
molta considerazione me ver que  yo no se
sovranità Bravo grazie jululu
ma osserva il video virale Mi sento davvero
bene oh hai sparato un fuoco ecco cos'è il
fuoco
Queen D siamo così Louie
McGary simulando in prossimità risolvi
tutti voi qualche patata con robota me come
osate ok io vivo anziano
signora inglese Archon un sensato fatto
valore sperimentale DJ Luigi okay
abbastanza Basilan Secondo DeMarco ragazzo
i cosacchi usano in particolare per i
dilemmi su internet sicuramente Erasmus ok
multi-monitor vedi llamo al bara per dire
l'assolo Teatro be in inglese Tara grant
rasool dentist romero even  è
differenziabile perché molto soprattutto
scusami scusami sì sei solo sì in
realtà sì posso sedermi qui bene
sei già seduto vuoi
qualcosa  ing per bere si grazie
panino con il cetriolo yeah Mayo
solo un secondo solo un senso certo vieni
qui da dove vieni
vengo da Roma Oh Italia ma sono nato in
Sicilia e tu vengo da Manchester oh
bello yeah  bello lo so e tu vivi a
Londra ma solo per un saluto sì
stiamo studiando una dozzina di studi ma è
molto prima per me
solo la mia opinione bene anche lui sembra sì
perché parlo molto
dormendo molto  di tasse
puoi per favore insegnami come fare la
carne di maiale alla carbonara Non so questo tuo nome lo
sai guancia un uovo esagonale
sì Oh per l'uovo per l'angolo no H
un uovo ehi no uovo un uovo non uno dipende
ok pepe  e basta no formaggio
formaggio tipo formaggio io John
pecorino in italiano li mette tutti
dentro il mio panino sta arrivando grazie oh
beh benvenuto
hmm ne vuoi un po' sì oh sì sì
oh mio dio Harry perché ti penso è
che potresti  essere l'
oratore inglese più avanzato della casa o oggi ho bisogno di
un ultimo no con  versetto a Zurigo a petrest
affari una risposta definitiva Otto brocco
hai mai pensato alla morte cioè
che la vita è noi siamo per l'universo una
piccola cosa come imprevedibile come qualsiasi
percettibile qualsiasi percettibile esistente in
esso ti consideri
più saggio audace I'  Sono piccoli gli anni in cui
c'erano meno di un granello di polvere o anche un
granello di sabbia nell'unità poi una bella
Hawaii certo o anche come una goccia d'acqua
nell'oceano se pensi che
tante stelle e non ricordo le stelle  è
davvero rumoroso,
non ho assistito a una cosa mossa prima,
mando così va bene no Nestor che non vede
nessun epitone ENT pero porta questa corsa per
saltare a la 3 5
[Risate
] andiamo esci piccoli modi per andare
bene contro è un'area che  Sento che ci
squilliamo in video così John prendiamo le
sigarette a un Rivera dato Majoris
pesto un sacramento richiesto presto a il
passero inglese un komodo sii triste o no
oh boo Tila un reato a Sochi vai a
proporre all'ufficio Intendo uomo cava
donne personalizzato  logica del sensore o  Il gusto del vomito del reggiseno o degli
aminoacidi è lo stesso